JEN PERSON: Hello.
I'm Jen Person for
the "Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google Photos
Library API gives you
the ability to build photo
and video experiences
in your products that
are faster, smarter,
and more helpful.
And it's now
generally available.
For an overview and links to the
docs, head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
The Cloud Firestore SDKs support
offline persistence on the web,
in addition to Android and iOS,
managing all your data locally
so you can execute
advanced queries
purely against the local cache.
And now the Cloud
Firestore Web SDK
has multi-tab
offline persistence,
so your users can read and
modify their local data
even when they open your
app in multiple tabs.
The code to turn it
on is on the post.
Cloud TPUs were designed
from the ground up
to train and run
cutting-edge ML models,
with each Cloud TPU
v2 delivering up
to 180 teraflops
of compute power,
and each Cloud TPU v3
providing up to 420 teraflops.
And now, Google-designed
Cloud TPUs
are publicly available in beta
on Google Kubernetes engine.
GKE also supports
preemptible Cloud TPUs
that are priced 70% lower than
the standard price of Cloud
TPUs.
Details are on the post.
Stackdriver Workspaces
are a place for you
to organize all the Stackdriver
resources you care about,
in ways that match your needs.
They can track your existing
Google Cloud Platform projects,
as well as any Amazon
Web Services accounts
that you want to monitor.
Screenshots and links to
get started are on the post.
We recently launched
the What-If Tool,
a new feature to the open-source
TensorBoard web application,
which allows you to analyze ML
model without writing any code.
Given pointers to a TensorFlow
model and a data set,
the What-If Tool offers an
interactive visual interface
for exploring model results.
Screenshots and links to
demos are on the post.
All known machine-learning
algorithms
are vulnerable to
adversarial examples, which
are inputs that an attacker has
intentionally designed to cause
the model to make a mistake.
The Unrestricted Adversarial
Examples Challenge
is a community-based
challenge to incentivize
a measure of progress
towards the goal
of zero confident classification
errors in machine learning
models.
For examples and a
link to participate,
take a look at the post.
Chrome 70 beta includes
the Shape Detection API,
updates to the Web
Authentication API, and more.
For details on all the
features in this release,
head on over to the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
the "Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
There's some great run-on
sentences in this one,
so it's going to be fun.
SPEAKER: Cool.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.